Zachary's in Kansas welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show Zachary Merry Christmas hey
hey what's up look I'm at 24 and I'm
wondering if I should file for
bankruptcy because I have about 20,000 a
medical debt and I owe two and a half
times more than what my current cars
worth it's about 22,000 on a car that's
only been appraised at 7 grand and
you're 20 years old
24 years old 24 okay and what do you
make a year 30 what do you do I'm a
delivery driver for Amazon okay
what's your game playing career-wise
over the next six years honestly I never
went to college or anything so I'm
probably gonna be stuck where I am at
now in six years well you will be if you
keep thinking that way
I mean you plan on driving an amazon
truck for the next 40 years that's not
that's not a good plan I hope no but you
need a better no not it's not about hope
you need a better plan you need to do
have a mindset of what I'm gonna do and
what it's going to take me to get me
there what do I want to do when I'm 30
years old that pays me $100,000 a year
$80,000 a year I don't care and what is
it I want to do for a living that I
enjoy doing and then I can make a good
living for me in my future family and so
forth and we need to look at that so
you're working 40 hours driving that
driving truck about 40 to 80 hours a
week right now is Christmas yeah well I
mean other than Christmas you're working
40 because during Christmas you make
more money they pay you by the hour
yes okay so you're making a lot of money
right now right now yes yeah okay then
I'll slow down after middle to the end
of January you still work a lot on the
returns after Christmas even okay so
what will be your income in in December
let's say probably five five hundred a
week and set them in all four hundred be
more than that if you're working 80
hours and being paid by the hour you're
not a double your income it just depends
some we say or capped at six days a week
for eight hours at 16:25 an hour so well
that's not that's not 80 hours some days
they'd still have my math is not that
good some days I don't even have routes
for us so some days I don't go home with
any pay at all
so gotcha all right okay so one thing we
need to do we've established is we need
to get you a better income and a more
stable predictable income you pick this
up because it was something to pay the
bills right I've been doing this for
four years it's just because driving
dreams all I've ever known my wife gets
mad at me but drive-ins all I've ever
known why does she get mad at you
because she doesn't want me on the road
I've been in three accidents and that's
where the skimmer most of our medical
bills are I say okay I've got a metal
rod in my back as it is what does she do
for a living I she's a stay-at-home mom
I see okay all right well the first
thing I want you to do Zachary is to
start thinking about your career field
and what you want to become and what
your steps are to become one of those
because eventually I want to own and be
what my bosses and just own a fleet of
bands instead of being the one actually
delivering everything I want to be the
one that owns the contracts and
everything else okay though there's a
goal that takes but that takes a lot of
money yeah so we have to figure out what
the steps are to get there and when I
asked you you said six years from now
I'm still going to be driving
six years from now I want you to own ten
trucks so let's figure out how to do
that all right that's the first thing
the second thing then is are you
bankrupt no you're not bankrupt you're
just scared not of control and you don't
know where the money's coming and where
the money's going and I wondered if
filing for bankruptcy would give me a
fresh start if it would be better it's
not it
but it's not necessary you've only got
$20,000 in debt on the medical and most
of that will take 20 we'll take 20 25
cents on the dollar if you need to call
them and negotiate with them and work
them down when you've got some money to
offer them in lump sum so meaning a two
thousand dollar bill will take four or
five hundred bucks a settlement in full
because old medical bills do from a
24-year old are not very collectible and
so they will work with you they will
settle don't put them on payments settle
lump sums and so you can settle that for
four or five thousand dollars and then
we've got to get this car mess
straightened out so who told you the car
was worth $7,000 I got appraised at a
dealership it's a Ford that's been in an
accident so it's worth less than what it
should be okay and why was it not
repaired when it was in the accident it
was repaired but they just deem it since
it was in an accident but Kelley Blue
Book value puts it down lower yeah so
it's the minute value but the car the
repair has been done yes the repair had
been done on the car that does not
explain why a $20,000 vehicles worth
seven well I haven't paid on it since
February so I've been compounding
interest and like B's okay why hasn't it
been repo'd I don't know I'm not hiding
the car I'm not doing anything I've told
them that they want to come get it they
can come get it but I just haven't been
able to financially afford it we got
roped into a dealer promise zero down
with a delivery driver at the time using
my own car and my car got hit I needed a
car and the dealer said well we can get
you in this car for zero down and we
didn't have any money saved up and I
needed the car for work so yeah so you
might so you made a stupid but decision
okay yeah all right I've done that too
right after I get desperate I usually
get broke and that's what happened to
you you know be careful when you get
desperate that's when you make dumb
decisions
so all right cool
well I think we work our way out of this
car work our way out of these things
we're going to get you on a written
budget and
have to do something to get your income
up and get your career moving in a
better and a different direction because
what you're describing to me is that you
are not making you're not working 80
hours but you're not getting the hours
you should be getting even in the month
of December which should be a bizarre
busy month for you so let's do two
things let's put you and your wife in
the Financial Peace University and we
will show you how to get on a budget and
we will show you how to start managing
the money that you have very carefully
and very tightly and then I'm also going
to send you a copy of Ken Coleman's
number one best-selling book called the
proximity principle and it's all about
your career in your career direction and
dude you are going to have to get off
your butt and intentionally do something
with this career or you're going to be a
40 year old with a metal rod in your
back still driving a van for Amazon and
you don't want to do that as an
intentional use of your precious life
your precious mom I thought you were
going to be something and do something
and you know why because you have the
ability to do something and be something
and I want you to do that there's no
shame in driving truck right now but
you've got to have a game plan or to be
something different or you won't be no
one accidentally succeeds at these
things so you want on a bunch of trucks
and contracts and run a trucking company
I got no issue with that at all it
sounds like a good plan to me
let's start figuring out how to do it
and start making the first steps to get
there and the first steps will be to get
rid of this debt without filing
bankruptcy you're not bankrupt you're
scared
disorganized out of control and you need
a better job than the one you have hold
on Kelly will pick up and help you guys
get started on this we will pay for
every bit of it we're gonna give it to
you as a gift the only thing we requires
you actually attend the class and that
someday when you're rich and famous you
find a scared 24 year old and you give
them the class for free as a gift one
Christmas merry Christmas to you sir